I'm no one's property and anyone who
thinks I can go [ __ ] themselves uh
what would your message be to Andrew
Tate is he gonna see this yeah really
today guys I am back doing another video
to find out what the public really think
about Andrew Tate I'm here on the
Streets of London to find out whether
people love him or whether they hate him
before we get into the video don't
forget to hit the like button and the
Subscribe button so you never miss a
video so do you guys know who Andrew
Tate is oh my God no ick no absolutely
not absolutely not why don't we like
Andrew Tate isn't it obvious I don't
know I'm asking people today quite a
horrendous person we love feminism and
not him this is Haram okay can you give
me an example of something that he said
which is anti-women he Advocates and
like recruits people to be against
women's rights basically does he yeah
can you tell me more about this well do
you want examples I'll get my Google out
I'd love examples let's see let's see if
we get some examples of how Andrew Tate
is advocating a group of men to sort of
take away the rights of women well the
guardian says that Andrew Tate says
women belong in the home can't drive in
our man's property I'm no one's property
and anyone who thinks I can go [ __ ]
themselves I think he sort of means they
take care of a woman the same way he'd
take care of his other property like his
house his car it means he's going to
look after her isn't that quite nice I
mean being someone's property is not
nice because I don't belong to anyone I
can take care of myself thank you very
much do you know who Andrew Tate is
do you like him he has a lot of
influence and it's dangerous he prefers
women who have slept with less men do
you agree what do you think
I think the
I think
it's a very strange
for a few
that actually can we go again do you
know who Andrew Tate is kind of I just
try and I he's someone that I've avoided
what about him don't you like you
obviously don't like him so what about
him specifically is the issue I think
people
um like him are
um violent and aggressive towards like
minorities and I'm just not you think
Andrew's violent towards minorities and
women no I don't think I don't think he
is I think he uh
it's what it's what like
in the comments I mean there's um
aggression on both sides that I don't
agree with if it's the comment section
that you don't like that's not really
Andrew's fault is it
um I think it has a certain anybody
that's kicking off in all that follows
you you have a responsibility
um as a public figure
um to
what kind of behavior do you feel like
he's encouraging
um
like
I hate speech primarily
um
like what hey switch like what I don't
know the
um I just think it's uh the people that
he involves himself with if you would
you want you you
and you take they never can get
can get congruent factual based stuff he
hasn't got criminal record like what was
he done that people don't like well I
think it's um to be honest with you the
um
I think it's this the kind of the
situation with
um
do you guys know who Andrew Tate is yeah
do you know who he is yeah do we like
him do we not like him oh no why not
massive misogynist can you define
misogyny men are better than women and
they're not hot wrong have you heard him
say men about than women though if
everything he said is like like what
I've actually heard him once say that
women are the most precious thing in the
world what do you think about that but
that's like in like olden times I know
like in Victorian times of a woman had
to like stay at home I think he's the
worst example for boys like our
generation what don't you like about him
why would it be bad for boys to be like
Andrew Tate
just like how he views women how does he
use women
um
oh my God I really don't know I don't
know what to say can you give me any
example of something that he's done
which is bad to women
no I can nothing comes to my head
actually I'm telling you I don't know
what to say so maybe he's not that bad
when you're out with a man would you
like him to sort of lead and maybe pay
for you no like 50 50. you don't want a
man to look after you and provide for
you no I want my own job so since we're
all equal and say you're on a date with
a guy and another man comes and tries to
like slap your bum what would you expect
your man to do he should like stick up
for it why now he's putting himself in
the firing line
yeah but what you go why don't you put
yourself in the firing line
but only equal when it comes to buying
dinner
review at all no why absolutely not
because I could take care of myself I'm
not a child my Granddaddy's attractive
child so whatever that's atrocious
that's disgusting like Andrew taste
attracted to Children Well 18 to 19 year
olds and how old is he he's 36 but
that's not a child we gotta we've got to
be careful with words it's not a child
it's not a child it's not a child but
it's very a big age Gap I think if it's
legal I think it's okay each to their
own as long as it's consensual don't you
think
you also spoke about not needing a man
but do you ever feel like sometimes you
know the world is kind of dangerous out
there like you don't want someone to
like protect you if somebody tries to
like hit on you or if a man comes and
grabs you or whatever it is I'm from New
York I'll kick your ass see if I give a
[ __ ] what if he's got a gun yeah you
think I haven't dealt with that I don't
know have you yes you walk around with a
gun no so we're in London there are no
guns here what if somebody's got a knife
I mean you run as fast as you can you
scream you make bloody murder you make
them want to run away
do you know who Andrew Tate is he says
like he only dates young girls and he's
what like 30 something why would you go
so young do you like older men I don't
like younger men I'm 24 and I've dated
like 21 year olds and it's not for me
why don't you like younger men they're
just less mature what if I said that's
sexist that you don't like younger men I
wouldn't say so
do you know who Andrew Tate is I mean
what I've heard of him is not good he is
part of human trafficking or something
like that what people keep saying that
he does human trafficking but he hasn't
been charged with anything at all
because he left the country you know so
the allegation was in Romania but
there's no evidence at all some people
keep saying these things but he hasn't
been charged with anything yeah but like
even what he says in his video I've
watched a little on Tick Tock as a
feminist I don't appreciate how he talks
about women Haram
is this a politician or something Andrew
Tate is a guy that's gone viral on Tick
Tock many months later I think that can
I ask you a question would you marry a
woman that's that with a hundred men
yes would you marry a woman that slept
with 500 men yes
it's absolutely just the case of a woman
a woman that slept with a thousand men
would you really marry her the fact
they've stayed with a thousand men won't
change anything
like that talking loud for like the guys
and stuff you come to the Sea like this
is changing a lot of guys life has
Andrew changed your life you have make
me laugh think of a way to make money
online like digital marketing and stuff
you know do you like Andrew Tate oh you
do like Andrew's hey what do you like
about him
thanks Andrew I like his forwardness and
I like that he's trying to get people
out of the Matrix and I like the fact
that he's trying to show or remind men
about masculinity because it's really
dying out in today's world how do you
know that he treats women badly he talks
about it in his video can you give me an
example because I haven't seen him say
anything bad or mean towards women
really because I've met him personally
and I've never experienced anything
negative and all you guys are have seen
is through Tick Tock yeah okay but if
you met him for a few minutes bro what
are you talking about man no I know
we're friends he's a friend he's a good
friend I've met him plenty of time do
you not think there's a problem with
judging people from what you see on the
internet things have been taken out of
context I saw just a lot of content
about him that was negative so but like
what can you give me an example I don't
know I like I said it was a few months
ago because now it's the the the thing
around him is a little over you're the
first person I've spoken to today that
actually likes Andrew Tate everybody
else has been screaming at me what do
you think of that some people have only
looked at the things that he says that
are quite controversial and they haven't
like actually taken time to actually
look at what he's really trying to say
or the message he's really trying to put
out one of the things that everyone has
an issue with is that he said women are
the property of men what's your take if
it comes to relationships I do believe
that the man prays a different role
compared to the woman yeah that's what
Andrew's saying and I actually agree I
think women are the property of their
husbands not random people like them
people exactly yes I agree with that as
well what would your message be to
Andrew Tate is he gonna see this yeah
really okay cool so to Andrew take I say
that you should continue doing what
you're doing because you're putting out
a message that most people in today's
world try to ignore I really appreciate
you mate and keep doing what you're
doing don't give up what a long day
interviewing all these different people
these crazy feminists I swear at one
point I thought I was gonna get hit but
as always people just don't like Andrew
Tate and they don't know why and you
know what the funny thing is every time
I press them they never know what to say
but don't worry guys because I'm gonna
be uncovering more about this so don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe because there's far more
videos coming